welcome to PlayStation VR if you've
already unboxed your PS we are all these
components are lying around your room
here's how to put it together into your
very own virtual reality system you
should already have a PlayStation camera
connected to your playstation 4 and
hopefully a playstation 4 connected to
your TV first step disconnect the hdmi
cable from the back of your playstation
4 and plug it into the back of the
processor unit leaving the other end
plugged into the TV next take the PS vr
hdmi cable labeled number one and use
that to connect the processor unit to
your ps4 you'll also need to connect
them with the USB cable labeled number
two by plugging one end into the ps4 and
the other end into the back of the
processor unit now let's get powered up
connect the AC power cord to the AC
adapter labeled number three plug the
other end of the AC adapter into the
back of the processor unit and the free
end of the AC power cord into your
favorite wall outlet with the VR headset
connection cable labeled for slide back
the front right side of the processor
unit to open those ports line up the
symbols on the plugs with the symbols
over the ports plug them in then slide
the cover back the other end plugs into
the VR headsets cord labeled number five
make sure that the symbols line up here
as well
plug in the stereo headphones into the
jack on the inline remote so you'll get
the full effect your own studio quality
noise cancelling bass dropping
headphones are fine too no offense taken
take a moment to make sure everything's
hooked up right okay now let's turn on
your TV then your PlayStation 4 and
PlayStation VR last you'll know
everything's connected properly when the
tracking lights on the back of the
headset start glowing blue when that
happens stand back for a moment and
admire your work you now have a virtual
reality system in your home all ready to
go all that's left is to get you ready
in part 3 of this tutorial